help is on the way for millions of
americans the house approving the final
version of president biden's 1.9
trillion dollar covid relief bill
no republicans voted for the bill the
bill extends the 300
a week unemployment benefits it also
includes a tax credit
of up to thirty six hundred dollars per
child direct stimulus checks could go up
by the end of the month the measure now
heads to
president biden's desk he is expected to
sign it on friday
as we've told you the plan includes a
third round of stimulus checks for
most americans and there is a lot of
money of it coming
of course to nevada the i-team's david
charns here with those details and
how much money you could see david yeah
we're talking about trillions of dollars
of money that's a lot so we've broken it
down for you just to talk about
how much this is more than 400 billion
in those direct checks combined
a combined 70 billion for cobit relief
in tracing 350 billion
going to state governments that includes
money for services like police the stuff
that keeps us going every day
now nevada gets 4 billion of that chunk
with about half a billion coming here to
clark county 130 million to the city of
las vegas
and nearly a billion dollars going over
to ccsd
now i spoke with one furloughed strip
employee today who happens to be a
mother of three
who says this just makes a big
difference for her family
we have to move up from the house
because we can't afford the ramps
anymore
so we're going through some really
really tough times right now
with money and you tell me that they're
passing this
out for me is it's like a relief
so will you get a check we'll take a
look at this if you make seventy five
thousand dollars a year or less or if
you're a couple that together
make one hundred fifty thousand or less
a year you are eligible for that
stimulus check that full fourteen
hundred dollars
twenty eight hundred dollars if you're a
couple and you file your taxes jointly
there's also that unemployment extension
of three hundred dollars a week through
september
and the child tax credit raised up to
thirty six
hundred dollars per child if that child
is between the ages of zero and six at
three thousand dollars if they're six to
seventeen
congressman stephen horsford voting in
favor of this today
i know listening to my constituents
they're worried about the rent
they're worried about food they're
worried about diapers
they're worried about keeping the
business open
and i have a responsibility in this
moment
to actually make sure that we deliver
and that's what this bill does
now as brian mentioned no republican
voted for this in the nevada republican
party calling this plan a quote
avenue for progressive democrats to pass
their radical agenda
now keep in mind the federal government
will base your most
recent tax return on how much money you
will get in all those credits they say
file your taxes as soon as possible if
you haven't already especially if you
had
life changes last year like if you lost
your job
or you had another child i'm david
charns 8 news now